now the first baby created from three
genetic parents has been born in the UK
the Breakthrough is aimed at stopping a
mother passing on defective genes to a
child the human fertilization and
embryology Authority says fewer than
five births have been recorded using the
procedure so let's take a look at how it
works
well nuclear DNA which defines
characteristics like personality and eye
cover it color is given to the embryo
from the mother and father
then a tiny amount of mitochondrial DNA
is provided by the third parent this
makes an embryo which contains both
healthy mitochondria from the donor and
nuclear DNA from the baby's mother and
father
the treatment is designed to prevent
potentially life-threatening inherited
diseases and genes from being passed on
from parents to their children
well our Science and Technology editor
Tom Clark is here and it's really
complicated to Tom isn't it but slightly
trying to simplify it it seems to me to
be that the the
what is being passed from the third
parent is almost the battery for the
sound it's not not what makes it
absolutely if you I I think one of the
things that maybe added to some of the
shock fact around this work was was the
headline conjured up by the media
calling it three parents babies which
isn't really that accurate the way it
does involve just information and donors
from from through individuals but
essentially what you're doing here is
taking a fertilized egg from a mother
who has is carrying mitochondria so
these little organs that are essentially
the power packs the batteries that live
in all of our cells of our body the
power out biology they're defective
um fortunately they sit outside of the
nucleus which contains all of the DNA
that makes you and I like we are so the
way this technique works is you take the
nucleus that which contains the mom and
dad's jet information what the baby will
inherit what each of us inherits but
leaves those the disease mitochondria
behind and you pop that into an empty
egg from a donut that's had its nucleus
removed but it has those healthy
mitochondria in it so you Pop That there
that's the third parent bid but actually
only 99. sorry less 99.8 to the DNA in
that egg is from Mum and Dad it's only a
tiny fraction of genetic material that's
contained in those mitochondria that's
passed on
but the benefits potentially for
children who are born with mitochondrial
diseases are huge because we know the
families in which these diseases can run
a parent knows that their potential risk
if this procedure can be implemented it
can have one in six one in six thousand
babies born in the UK has a
mitochondrial disease these can be fatal
or life limiting they can because
mitochondria power every cell in the
body they can have you know very diverse
uh problems problems with neural
neurological diseases linked to
mitochondria problems with muscles other
organs in the body metabolic disorders
so the potential is is really really
great
um the UK changed the law to allow this
process to happen it's not a world first
it's been done once before
um and in in well a few times before
once successfully uh in the in in North
America a few years ago but we've got a
system do it we have a regulatory
environment here in the UK that's that's
that's allowing it to happen so it could
be a real learning for
um for the the the the the the the
world's embryologist who wants to sort
of develop this technique but also a
service that the NHS can now provide and
I suppose briefly it all it all means
that very often in these cases if you
are susceptible to mitochondrial DNA
issues it means you can't get pregnant
often you know the mum will miscarry
repeatedly so either having problems
yeah and also because of this Lottery
idea because it's not a guarantee that
the baby will inherit the the the
disease mitochondria from the mother but
if they do they're going to have this
condition so this allows you an option
to get around it what is very important
though we found out about these births
happening through a freedom of
information request by the guardian
because the authorities decided not to
publicize because they don't want to
identify the patients which is entirely
understandable what is very important
now is that we do see some scientific
publication associated with this we need
to see scientific Publications about the
follow-up of these babies to learn is
this a viable technique there are
slightly there are slightly tweaked
other ways of doing it as well so is
this the most uh promising technique are
there going to be any complications
associated with it we we need that
openness right now that work is yet to
to be forthcoming but that's something
the scientific Community is certainly
going to be looking out for but it does
raise real promise for parents living
with the possibility of much quantities
to give them an option to conceive
healthy for her babies good stuff Tom
thanks very much